die schlacht um die wagenburg beginnt
gegen 10 uhr mit einer flex versuchen
die beamten einen räumungsbeschluss
umzusetzen dabei werden sie immer wieder
von randalierern attackiert die beamten
versuchen herr der lage zu werden das
chaos einzudämmen und unsere
bild-reporter mittendrin
es wurden erste demonstranten
festgenommen auf dem boden gehalten die
polizei angefangen pfefferspray
einzusetzen weil die demonstraten
angefangen haben die barrikaden
herunterzureißen
schon in der nacht gab es
ausschreitungen unbekannte schlagen laut
polizei im stadtteil kreuzberg
autoscheiben ein bewerfen häuser mit
farbbeutel auch vor bränden bleibt die
hauptstadt nicht verschont
bauschuttcontainer mülltonnen greifen
und autos gehen in der nacht entlang
augenzeugen berichten zudem dass eine
gruppe von 50 bis 100 vermummten
personen versuchte eine barrikade an der
köpenicker straße 137 zu errichten ziel
die räumung zu verhindern
mit dem wagen kopie soll heute eines der
letzten symbol projekte der
linksalternativen szene in berlin
geräumt werden seit über 30 jahren ist
das rund 2600 quadratmeter große
grundstück bereits besetzt der
eigentümer hatte mit hinweis auf eine
baugenehmigung im juni erfolgreich auf
eine räumung geklagt jetzt will die
gerichtsvollzieherin mit hilfe der
beamten das gelände übernehmen dafür
sind heute insgesamt 2000 kräfte aus
acht bundesländern im einsatz
unterstützt von der bundespolizei
die beamten stellen sich auf eine
erneute eskalation der lage ein die
größte demo mit 500 teilnehmern unter
dem motto kopie bleibt keine räumung in
berlin startet dann am abend um 20 uhr
am kottbusser damm und soll am kopi
vorbeiführen
diese hoffnung ist jetzt dieser
illegalen siedlung in vollem gange die
bundespolizei konnte bereits auf das
gelände durch drängen wir wollen hier
auch einmal die live bilder zeigen denn
die polizei es immer noch damit
beschäftigt dort menschen abzuführen
unsere kollegin klara maria becker die
ist für uns vor ort ebenso wie peter
wilke sie beobachten das was jetzt
gerade passiert in der hauptstadt denn
es sind mehrere auch dezentrale aktionen
angekündigt auch jasmin jahres unsere
reporterin sehen wir hallo euch rein
schön dass hier bei uns seit wir schauen
als erstes einmal zu dir peter wir
konnten ihn gerade beobachten dass die
räumung dort weiter vorangeht dass die
beamten versuchen sich ihren weg zu
bahnen wie beobachtest du derzeit diese
räumungsaktion
ja patricia die räumung geht jetzt hier
wirklich schritt für schritt voran ich
würde schätzen mittlerweile sind schon
über zehn besetzer abgeführt worden
festgenommen aus diesem gelände heraus
gebracht worden außerdem rund 100
einsatzkräfte jetzt mittlerweile drinnen
haben sich den weg ein gebannt auf das
gelände um eben dort die besetzer
festzunehmen und herauszuholen es geht
jetzt hier stück für stück voran immer
wieder werden neue personen heraus
geführt die höhenretter sind
mittlerweile auch auf dem gelände um
eben die person die sich auf bäumen
befinden dort herunterzuholen und das
vielleicht auch noch mal zur erklärung
es geht hier wirklich nur um den
vorplatz der geräumt und frei gemacht
werden soll das gebäude was dort hinter
gesteht dass es zwar auch besetzt das
ist aber sozusagen egal besetzt darum
geht es ganz es geht nur um das gelände
davor und da möchte eben bereits schon
seit 2015 also seit sechs jahren der
eigentümer eben drauf bauen möchte das
gelände zurück haben seitdem wurde es
nicht hergegeben und jetzt wird das eben
hier von der polizei gewaltsam
durchgesetzt und es geht stück für stück
voran im moment relativ ruhig wie wir
hinter dir sehen können peter das heißt
dort gehen die beamten einfach sozusagen
schritt für schritt voran haben jetzt
verschiedentlich menschen dort abgeführt
von dem gelände beschreibt noch mal was
du in den vergangenen zwei drei stunden
aber dort gesehen hast denn die lage war
ja nicht immer so ruhig wie jetzt
genau jetzt gerade ist es tatsächlich
relativ entspannt jetzt spielt sich das
meiste drinnen ab alle die hier
ausgeführt wurden haben sich auch nicht
großartig gewährt so wie wir es
beobachten konnten aber du hast es
angesprochen vor allen dingen um 10 uhr
als hier die gerichtsvollzieher in
herangekommen ist um eben diese räumung
durchzuführen um eben die besetzer
zuerst fried nicht zu bieten also
friedlich dort raus zu kommen das
wollten sie nicht tun die
gerichtsvollzieherin hat sich dann
direkt zurückgezogen es gar nicht erst
nachher angekommen weil sie zu nicht
möglich erachtet hat was es ja auch
nicht wahr und dann gab es hier
ordentlich krawalle erstmal natürlich
von drinnen aus wurden gegenstände auf
die straße geworfen flaschen in richtung
der polizisten wurden immer wieder
feuerwerkskörper gezündet auch auf die
straße geschmissen ja und 50 meter
weiter links von diesem gelände dort
stand dann auch noch der schwarze block
mit 200 personen ungefähr und hat sich
dort verschiedene auseinandersetzung mit
den polizeikräften geliefert dort gab es
dann auch festnahm dort gab es immer
wieder kabel 1 und krawalle sind auch
gegenstände geflogen ja so sah es hier
vor zwei stunden aus jetzt hat sich das
ganze eben ein bisschen beruhigt und die
beamten können ihre arbeit hier
fortführen ihre arbeit die aber im am
ende immer noch daran besteht straftäter
besetzer eine illegale besetzung
aufzulösen und sich da eben auch mit
einer gewissen gegenwehr stellen zu
müssen peter vielen herzlichen dank
ihren weg gehen zu clara maria becker
denn du standest genau dort wo vorher
diese tour schon auch kurzzeitig mal
eskaliert ist ja die linke szene die hat
eine schlacht angekündigt was genau ist
er heute in der hauptstadt für den laufe
des tages und auch für die nacht geplant
wer heute abend ab 20 uhr soll die tag
xd muss stattfinden
die hier einmal durch doch natürlich
kreuzberg führt und die polizei hat uns
auch schon gesagt da wird auf jeden fall
noch mal mit ausschreitungen gerechnet
jetzt gerade ist es ja auch entspannter
noch von der stunde später hat es ja
schon beschrieben was hier los war haben
sie auch in den bildern gesehen wir
standen mittendrin da wurden auf einmal
beim absperrungen geschmissen da wurde
mit flaschen geworfen mit fahrrädern und
die polizisten mussten auch wirklich
ganz entschieden reingehen und bestimmte
personen schon festnehmen jetzt gerade
hatte sich wieder ein bisschen beruhigt
zwischendurch das nimmer so kleine
anzeichen also man demonstranten sind
irgendwann hier raus gegangen haben sich
regenschirme geholt die vorne in der
ersten reihe aufgespannt genau gegenüber
vor ihren gesichtern gegenüber der
polizisten und da weiß man schon okay
wir rechnen jetzt mit mit kaká spielt
zum beispiel und wollen sich dagegen
schützen das ist mir so kleine anzeichen
wie man das gefühl hat jetzt könnte es
nochmals skalieren genau wie vor einer
stunde kann es nämlich dann auf einmal
sehr schnell gehen das haben sich jetzt
allerdings nach und nach auf mehrere
teilnehmer entfernt weil über die
lautsprecheransagen nochmal gesagt wurde
verteilt euch auf alle drei punkte hier
sind ja drei kundgebungen rund um den
kirchplatz und offensichtlich möchte man
da jetzt den standpunkt oder den
schwerpunkt von dieser demo auf eine auf
die andere seite verlegen und darin wir
natürlich dennoch weiß mal hingehen
ja und um das einmal ganz kurz für
unsere zuschauer einzuordnen peter hatte
das vorher auch getan klare du hast dir
vorübergehenden helm eingesetzt weil
eben vorher die aufgesetzt weil eben
vorhin die lage kurz relativ
unübersichtlich war weil dort auch
gegenstände geflogen sind und die
polizei hat wie du es ja auch berichtet
hass unter anderem auch pfefferspray
eingesetzt sind genau dieser situation
weiter zu unserer kollegin jasmin ja wo
ist die an einem der eingänge an einem
dieser zutritts punkte zu diesem gelände
steht und vielleicht kannst du uns
nochmal unseren zuschauern die nicht in
berlin leben und ein bisschen zeigen was
ist das für ein gelände wie groß welche
zutritts punkte gibt es dort
[Musik]
aber vielleicht noch mal gerade kurz
die polizei die jetzt hier ihre leiter
vorbereitet um nämlich
menschen aus der linksautonomen szene
aus diesem areal aus den bäumen zu holen
es ist nämlich so es haben sich hier
noch ein zwei drei kann ich momentan
sehen die sich noch an die erste
festgeklammert haben haben sich dort
fest gebunden weil sie eben sagen wir
wollen dieses areal hier einfach nicht
verlassen von der schlacht von der du
immer wieder spricht ich glaube man
sieht so langsam die schlacht scheint
mehr oder weniger
verloren auch wenn sie nicht kampflos
aufgegeben wird das vielleicht einmal
vorab und um auf eine andere frage
einzugehen
dieses areal befindet sich hier mitten
in berlin du sagst es ja auch immer
wieder das ist nur zehn minuten vom axel
springer haus entfernt also es wir sind
quasi an der grenze mitte
kreuzberg es ist ein riesiges areal
eines der letzten linksautonomen
projekte hier in der hauptstadt das
jetzt eben geräumt werden wird
es minen jahres peter wilke und klara
marie becker herzlichen dank euch hier
verfolgt weiterhin für uns als
reporterinnen und reporter im einsatz
was dort gerade in der hauptstadt
passiert
[Musik]